[Music]
welcome to rotten tomatoes countdown
brought to you by disney and pixar's
lightyear you know his name now discover
his story only in theaters june 17th in
1995 disney distributed pixar's toy
story as an autumn alternative to
traditional 2d animated features after
the film's release pixar set the gold
standard for theatrical animated films
for decades to come
now almost 27 years later pixar revisits
our heroic friend with the highly
anticipated release of lightyear taking
a more realistic approach this movie
explores the origin story of one of the
most iconic and fan favorite characters
within the pixar vault buzz lightyear
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned
our first hyper speed test flight is a
go who are you talking about uh no one
you were narrating again i was not just
doing the mission log you do know no one
ever listens to that i know that
narrating helps me focus which brings us
to our list today
we've previously made a list for the top
10 pixar movies and all of those were
ranked by tomato meter from the critics
for this list we're focusing on the
audience for while the more popular
pixar films will appear here we'll see
some that didn't make the previous list
we've done we're excited to talk about
some of the more under the radar pixar
movies presented by disney and pixar's
lightyear so to infinity and beyond
let's count down the best fan favorite
pixar movies
[Music]
number 10 soul
joe is a middle school band teacher
whose life hasn't quite gone the way he
expected his true passion is jazz and
he's good but when he travels to another
realm to help someone find their passion
he soon discovers what it means to have
soul starring jamie foxx tina fey
felicia rashad and directed by pete
doctor critics say a film as beautiful
to contemplate as it is to behold soul
proves pixar's power to deliver
outstanding all ages entertainment
remains undimmed
you know what that's gonna say joe
gardner
you're never gonna believe what just
happened i did it i got the gig yes
i i don't know i know dorothea williams
can't just believe it hey pal you're
gonna get hurt just don't tell my mom
about this
okay
forget class
i'm in a different class i'm in the
dorothea williams class buddy you know
what i'm saying
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
hello
number nine inside out
riley is a happy hockey loving 11 year
old midwestern girl but her world turns
upside down when she and her parents
moved to san francisco riley's emotions
led by joy try to guide her through this
difficult life-changing event however
the stress of the movie brings sadness
to the forefront when joy and sadness
are inadvertently swept into the far
reaches of riley's mind the only
emotions left in headquarters are anger
fear and disgust starring amy poehler
phyllis smith bill hader and directed by
pete doctor critics say inventive
gorgeously animated and powerfully
moving inside out is another outstanding
addition to the pixar library of modern
animated classics
here we go all right open
this looks new think it's safe what is
it
okay caution there is a dangerous smell
people hold on what is that this is
disgust she basically keeps riley from
being poisoned physically and socially
that is not brightly colored or shaped
like a dinosaur hold on guys it's
broccoli
well i just saved our lives yeah you're
welcome riley if you don't eat your
dinner you're not gonna get any dessert
wait did he just say we couldn't have
dessert that's anger he cares very
deeply about things being fake so that's
how you want to play it old man no
dessert oh sure we'll eat our dinner
right after you eat this
[Music]
right here comes an airplane
oh airplane we got an airplane everybody
[Music]
number eight
wally
wally short for waste allocation load
lifter earth class is the last robot
left on earth he spends his days tidying
up the planet one piece of garbage at a
time but for 700 years wally has
developed a personality and he's more
than a little lonely then he spots eva a
sleek and shapely probe sent back to
earth on a scanning mission smit and
wally embarks on his greatest adventure
yet when he follows eva
across the galaxy starring ben berg
alyssa knight fred willard and directed
by andrew stanton critics say wally's
stellar visuals testify once again to
pixar's ingenuity while its charming
star will captivate younger viewers and
its timely story offers
thought-provoking subtext
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
number seven toy story three
with their beloved andy preparing to
leave for college woody buzz jesse and
the rest of the toys find themselves
headed for the attic but mistakenly wind
up on the curb with the trash woody's
quick thinking saves a gang but all but
woody end up being donated to a daycare
center unfortunately the uncontrollable
kids do not play nice so woody and the
gang make plans for a great escape
starring tom hanks tim allen joan cusack
and directed by lee unkrich critics say
deftly blending comedy adventure and
honest emotion toy story 3 is a rare
second sequel that really works
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
that i could catch the tree
now let's catch some criminals go
infinity and beyond
number six up
carl frederickson a 78 year old balloon
salesman is about to fulfill a lifelong
dream tying thousands of balloons to his
house he flies away to the south
american wilderness but curmudgeonly
carl's worst nightmare comes true when
he discovers a little boy named russell
is a stowaway aboard the balloon-powered
house starring ed asner christopher
plummer jordan nagai and directed by
pete doctor and bob peterson critics say
an exciting funny and poignant adventure
up offers an impeccably crafted story
filled with wit and arranged with depth
as well as yet another visual pixar
treat
my name is doug i have just met you and
i love you
my master made me this collar he is a
good and smart master and he made me
this color so that i may talk squirrel
master is good and smart it's not
possible oh it is because my master is
smart
cool what it is
i use that collar watch
to talk with i would be happy if you
stop russell don't touch that it could
be radioactive or something i am a great
tracker my pack sent me on a special
mission all by myself have you seen a
bird i want to find one and i've been on
this scent i'm a great tracker did i
mention that
hey that is the bird i have never seen
one up close but this is the bird may i
take your bird back to camp as my
prisoner yes yes take it and on the way
learn how to bark like a real dog i can
bark
and here's howling
[Music]
number five monsters inc
monsters incorporated is the largest
scare factory in the monster world and
james p sullivan is one of its top
scarers sully is a huge intimidating
monster with blue fur large purple spots
and horns his scare assistant best
friend and roommate is mike wazowski a
green opinionated feisty little one-eyed
monster visiting from the human world is
boo a tiny girl who goes where no human
has ever gone before starring john
goodman billy crystal mary gibbs and
directed by pete doctor
critics say clever funny and delightful
to look at monster zinc delivers another
resounding example of how pixar elevated
the bar for modern all ages animation
[Music]
[Music]
hey
may the best monster win
i plan to
we are on in seven
six
five
three
two
number four toy story
woody a good-hearted cowboy doll who
belongs to a young boy named andy sees
his position as andy's favorite toy
jeopardized when his parents buy him a
buzz lightyear action figure even worse
the arrogant buzz thinks he's a real
spaceman on a mission to return to his
home planet when andy's family moves to
a new house woody and buzz must escape
the clutches of maladjusted neighbor sid
phillips and reunite with their boy
starring tom hanks tim allen don rickles
and directed by john lasseter critics
say entertaining as it is innovative toy
story reinvigorated animation while
heralding the arrival of pixar as a
family-friendly force to be reckoned
with
[Music]
[Music]
look out
hold on to my face
[Music]
[Music]
they're running out wow
[Music]
[Music]
despite his family's generation's old
ban on music young miguel dreams of
becoming an accomplished musician like
his idol ernesto de la cruz desperate to
prove his talent miguel finds himself in
the stunning and colorful land of the
dead after meeting a charming trickster
named hector the two friends embark on
an extraordinary journey to unlock the
real story behind miguel's family
history starring anthony gonzalez gael
garcia-bernal benjamin bratt and
directed by lee unkrich
critics say coco's rich visual pleasures
are matched by a thoughtful narrative
that takes a family-friendly and deeply
affecting approach to questions of
culture family life and death
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta stay with me boys
[Music]
this isn't a dream then
you're all really out there you thought
we weren't well i don't know i thought
it might have been one of those made up
things that adults tell kids like
vitamins number two toy story four
woody buzz and the rest of the gang
embark on a road trip with bonnie and a
new toy named forkey the adventurous
journey turns into an unexpected reunion
as woody's slight detour leads him to
his long-lost friend bo peep as woody
and bo discuss the old days they soon
start to realize that they're worlds
apart when it comes to what they want
from life as a toy
starring tom hanks annie potts tony hale
and directed by josh cooley critics say
heartwarming funny and beautifully
animated toy story 4 manages the
unlikely feat of extending and perhaps
concluding a practically perfect
animated saga
trash
no no it's okay
i have a question um well actually not
just one i have all of them i have all
the questions uh why does he want to go
to the trash because he was made from
trash look i know this is a little
strange but you got to trust me on this
forky is the most important toy to
bonnie right now important he's a sport
yes yeah i know but this sport this toy
is crucial to bonnie getting adjusted to
kindergarten oh woody aren't you being a
little dramatic about all this i know
this is new to everybody but you should
see how much this little guy means to
bonnie which she started playing with
him she had the biggest smile on her
face i wish you could have seen it
bonnie was really upset and i swear once
she made forkie it was a complete
transformation oh just a second jesse so
we all have to make sure nothing happens
to him something happened to him
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
turning red
in turning red maylie is a confident
dorky 13 year old torn between staying
her mother's dutiful daughter and the
chaos of adolescence and as if changes
to her interests relationships and body
weren't enough whenever she gets too
excited she poops into a giant red panda
starring rosalie xiong sandra oh ava
morse and directed by domi she critics
say heartwarming humorous beautifully
animated and culturally expansive
turning red extends pixar's long list of
family-friendly triumphs are you a
werewolf no what
he's a red pepper sick you're so fluffy
you're so fluffy i've always wanted a
tail priya abby quit it
made what the heck happened it's just
some you know
inconvenient uh
genetic thingy i got for my mom
i mean
it'll go away
eventually
maybe
i
hate this
i'm sloppy i'm smelly
my mom won't even look at me and
no poor town
when are they coming may 18th they just
announced it the 18th
there's no way this will be gone by then
just just go
go become women without me
it's gonna be okay no it's not i'm
i'm a freak
just
just leave me alone
a bug's life
flick is an inventive ant who's always
messing things up for his colony his
latest mishap was destroying the food
stores that were supposed to be used to
pay off grasshopper hopper
now the strong arming insect is
demanding that the ants gather double
the food or face annihilation to avert
disaster flit goes on a journey to
recruit fighters to defend the colony
when he meets a band of high-flying
circus insects he thinks he's found his
salvation starring dave foley julia
louis-dreyfus hayden panettiere and
directed by john lasseter and andrew
stanton critics say a bug's life is a
rousing adventure that blends animated
thrills with witty dialogue and
memorable characters and another
smashing early success for pixar
they're here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone
everyone
to the offering stone
okay everyone single file food to the
offering stone and into the anthill now
let's go
[Music]
before we get to number one we want to
highlight the latest and greatest
addition to the pixar repertoire
light year
buzz lightyear embarks on an
intergalactic adventure with a group of
ambitious recruits and his robot
companion pixar goes beyond infinity in
their timeless saga once more giving us
an expansive look into the heroic origin
story of buzz lightyear while we see the
return of some familiar characters like
the evil emperor zerg and buzz himself
lightyear also adds a diverse ensemble
of new faces and worlds for us to fall
in love with taking the torch from tim
allen who originally voiced buzz chris
evans unravels a new layer of buzz
bringing our favorite toy exceptionally
to life starring chris evans taikowa tt
kiki palmer james brolin and directed by
angus mclean
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
anyone saying the
[Music]
harpoons right here
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 hmm seems a
bit low
mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
speak or select one
finally number one onward
teenage elf brothers ian and barley
embark on a magical quest to spend one
more day with their late father like any
good adventure their journey is filled
with cryptic maps impossible obstacles
and unimaginable discoveries but when
dear mom finds out her sons are missing
she teams up with the legendary
manticore to bring her beloved boys back
home starring tom holland chris pratt
julia louis-dreyfus and directed by dan
scanlon critics say it may suffer in
comparison to pixar's classics but
onward makes effective use of the
studio's formula and stands on its own
merits as a funny heartwarming dazzling
animated adventure
uh come on why would it start there's a
sweet spot not in the middle not quite
at the end come on come on
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you don't have a signaler move your arms
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and be on
the lookout for disney pixar's new
release light year
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you